[Music]
it's so funny to walk down the street
because like dudes walking by and
they're like yes newly-engaged Ariana
Grande and Pete Davidson seriously can't
contain their excitement contest whether
it's Pete gushing about his leading lady
on The Tonight Show or Ariana paying
tribute to her man with the song on her
upcoming sweetener album give me the
breakdown for the song these two have
restored our faith in love the 24 year
old comedians penned a sweet birthday
message to Arianna Pete captioned his
first playful shot of the couple happy
birthday to the most precious angel on
earth you're my favorite person that
ever existed he followed it up with a
second snap writing one more for the
Queen but it's the 25 year old singers
birthday post that really says it all
quote I have no wish I have everything I
ever wanted
hi and if that's not enough Pete and
Ariana cuteness let's talk about the
time they managed to make rug shopping
look like a scene from a romantic comedy
after announcing they moved in together
and we're living with no furniture
[Music]
there's the time ari and Pete got new
ink in matching locations but there's
nothing cuter than the time the duo got
decked out in Harry Potter garb just
because let me know he would like
impressive world's favorite scarf